I would say it is traditional at this
point in the show when John Bishop is on
the couch to turn to the Americans say
understanding anything he said he was in
the Fellowship of the Ring talking
talking about sense this is a weird
thing so Chris Pratt is this this seems
so unlikely that you have now learned to
how to do the voices from TOWIE yeah
sort of yeah we love that garbage TV
crazy about it and when I was here
filming guardians we shot guardians the
galaxy here in London and and my wife on
a came out to visit and she fell in love
with this show TOWIE The Only Way Is
Essex it's this show that's like
basically their jersey shorts the Jersey
Shore from from here it's like this town
somewhere Essex I guess I'm a parrot a
little bit and so when I hear when I
hear it all the time I just started
picking it up and started like I could
pick up their accent and do their accent
a little bit no no yeah I'm okay it's
gonna sound really embarrassing to do in
front of a whole room full of Brits here
but I'll try it anyways so it's like so
I want to say like a Suisse car
they'd like Michael cheat on me when to
be far but these tiny sigh you know you
know unless you or whatever
Oh me
we'll never be useful never be useful
but it's very good months and that's
what you saw
an area in LA that's like a
predominantly gay area and I was there
getting hedge getting we are who's
number two
[Applause]